the remnants of hurricane ida are
continuing to wreak havoc across the
northeastern united states the national
weather service declared its first ever
flash flooding emergency for new york
city as ida dumped a month's worth of
rain in a matter of hours several people
have died subway and air travel has been
suspended and thousands are without
power earlier the storm spawned
destructive tornadoes as it advanced
north
new york underwater
the deluge turned roads into rivers
flooding the city forcing the airports
to close
and the mayor to declare a state of
emergency
neighboring new jersey suffered a
similar fate
it may no longer be a hurricane but as a
downgraded tropical storm ida is still
wreaking havoc now in the north eastern
u.s
in pennsylvania maryland and virginia
the storm prompted thousands of
evacuations
residents were shocked at how quickly it
brought about its devastation
it was pretty quick
wind maybe five minutes
and then
just everything was decimated
so i turned off the radio and
just heard everything there like the
roof everything collapsing so we
ida made landfall as a category 4
hurricane in louisiana on sunday where
four people lost their lives the storm
disrupted electricity and water supplies
for millions of people before it tracked
north to cause further damage in
mississippi and tennessee and then on to
new york and new jersey where empty and
abandoned cars now sound the alarm and
are the eerie backdrop for the rescue
and massive cleanup task ahead
well earlier dw spoke to meteorologist
matthew capucci about the situation in
new york
this event is unlike anything we've seen
a recent memory and realistically
anything i've seen in my career newark
new jersey picked up 8.2 centimeters of
rain in just one hour's time they got 21
centimeters for the day that's their
entire rainfall record obliterated many
places seeing upwards of 10 centimeters
of rain every single hour in new york
city saw 15.2 centimeters in just a
couple hours time we had widespread
totals over 20 centimeters so this
really was a high-end event a lot of
places seeing their their entire month's
worth of rainfall coming down in one
hour's time we have water rescues
ongoing right now the subways are
flooding underground they have no way to
escape a lot of people are likely uh in
situations they shouldn't be in right
now we do have reports of fatalities and
tornadoes have been spinning up too i
chased one today this is an event that
we'll remember for quite some time